what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
there are many
different awesome superhero teams coming
to the
mcu like the new avengers the young
avengers the thunderbolts and a lot more
which i'll talk about in this video but
perhaps
one of the coolest teams is a
supernatural avengers group
the midnight suns which are reportedly
coming to the
mcu relatively soon and the lineup for
the midnight suns is reportedly already
set
and it's a really good one that i think
many people are going to thoroughly
enjoy because
if you caught my video the other day you
know that it means characters like
ghostwriter are finally going to be
entering the mcu
so i'll break down this new report and
talk about the characters that are going
to make up the
new midnight sun supernatural team and
talk about the villains also
that the midnight suns could be going up
against in the mcu
reminder only 12 days left in my
stormbreaker giveaway all you have to do
to enter subscribe to my channel and
cosmic culture link in the description
down below so if you caught my video
a couple of days ago you know that
ghostwriter is reportedly on his way to
the mcu in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
and it looks like that film is going to
be where the midnight
suns team starts to assemble that's the
start of their team coming together now
originally it was just reported that
ghost rider was coming but now we have
an idea of what his teammates
on this team are going to look like the
ghost writer report came from
that hashtag show and this report is
also coming from them as well
in their report they state that this
week they can exclusively share that
marvel is working on a midnight suns
movie which is currently in early
development they go on to say that the
midnight suns is a group within marvel
comics that consist
of supernatural heroes that fight
supernatural threats and marvel studios
is wanting to build the midnight suns to
be
the supernatural avengers team more or
less
and then they say something pretty
interesting they say that while there
have been previous reports regarding the
midnight suns being adapted into the mcu
they were inaccurate at the time
apparently marvel didn't have all of the
characters that they wanted in place for
the film
however now with blade and moon knight
coming to the mcu
and the doctor strange sequel bringing a
lot of characters into the mcu it's now
a big
priority for marvel and a realistic one
according to that hashtag show
now as far as the team is concerned they
say that the roster will start off small
and grow in future films as with any
team-up film it will start with doctor
strange
moon knight blade hannibal king
hellstrom
ghost rider and the scarlet witch
hannibal king
and hellstrom will reportedly be
introduced in blade and fleshed out
further in midnight sons while ghost
rider will be utilized in doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness before
continuing on in the midnight suns
and of course moon knight has a series
coming up on disney plus and blade is
going to have a movie
now the report also reveals who the
villain is reportedly going to be
they claim that while plot details are
scarce as this is still in early
development they can exclusively share
that blackout will be the primary
villain with teases
of mephisto throughout here we go again
let's just start right now throw all of
the mephisto theories out there let's
just get him out there right now
kevin feige is mephisto confirmed now
we'll talk about the villain
and the lineup in just a bit but let's
talk about the different
teams inside of the mcu first now this
really does seem like a direction that
marvel studios is heading
branching out into various different
parts and teams of their already giant
universe and this is great news for us
because that only means that we're going
to be getting
more different content more content
we've had reports for a while now
stating that the mcu will be broken up
into two major groups a cosmic side and
an earth side and yes i will be taking
my full claim on the cosmic
side and i will call my heroes the
cosmic
avengers if you're listening marvel make
it happen but on these different
sides there is clearly going to be many
different teams and the supernatural
team is going
to be one of them and then i think
there's going to be one major group that
controls all of the other teams and that
is going to be the illuminati so let me
break it down for you on the earth side
we're going to have teams like the new
avengers the young avengers the dark
avengers hopefully
the midnight suns or the supernatural
avengers the thunderbolts and any other
crazy cool team
that marvel could be hiding from us
right now then you have the cosmic side
or the side that's going to be
addressing all of the
problems and villains outside of earth
they will have their own avengers team
of course we'll call them the cosmic
avengers they'll have the guardians of
the galaxy
thor of course who will most likely be a
part of the new cosmic avengers team
or perhaps he'll get the revengers back
together has it got a name
yeah it's called the revenges revenges
because i'm getting revenge you're
getting revenge and you're
i'm just undecided after all the loki
series is going to bring in many
different loki's maybe
one of them will stick around then we
have the marvels which will be captain
marvel
miss marvel and monica rambo with her
new powers making her one of the marvels
all of these characters will come
together in captain marvel 2 which will
also be a part of the secret invasion
storyline so this is kind of going to
take place on the cosmic side
and the earth side then if kevin feige
ever gets working on the nova film he
keeps talking about we could have
nova and maybe have the novacore return
as well
so you have your earthbound teams and
then you have the space or cosmic teams
and then i think they'll both be
controlled by the illuminati
in the comics that's really what the
illuminati is it's pretty much
a council of all of the leaders of all
of the different teams
tony stark from the avengers mr
fantastic from the fantastic four
professor x from the x-men so on and so
forth it's obviously going to be
different in the mcu
but with so many teams in the mcu it
would make sense that they would need a
group that kind of communicates between
all of them they're all trying to defend
the earth and or
universe so they're kind of gonna all
need to be in sync and the illuminati
could be just what they need
now i could probably talk for years
let's be honest and i probably will talk
for years about all of these different
teams but let's keep it focused on the
recently announced team
the midnight suns in this report they
mention a very specific
roster for the team one that will
probably get a lot of people excited
and one that's a little different from
the original lineup in the comics now
most of these characters fit in this
team
pretty well and all of which have pretty
much been on the team in the comics
doctor strange moon knight blade
hannibal king hellstrom ghost rider but
then they mentioned the scarlet witch
which is
pretty cool to hear because of the path
that she's currently going on
after one division she is now embracing
more of the witch side of herself
getting more into that supernatural side
and she's learning from a very
supernatural
and evil book the darkhold this is all
going to lead up into doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness in which we
believe
she is ultimately going to end up
helping dr steven strange defeat an evil
demon of some sort and this is where
ghost rider is also supposed to appear
as well so this
is going to be the start of the midnight
suns where you have doctor strange the
scarlet witch and
ghost writer if all of these reports end
up being accurate but this will start
the team
and then much like the avengers was
built up this team will be built up as
well until they all come together to
fight a villain
but who are the villains mephisto
confirmed i'm only partly kidding
because i do think that he is eventually
going to be coming to the mcu
in this report they claim that mephisto
is in the works over at marvel studios
and this simply makes sense
if we're going down this supernatural
path with demons and evil gods it only
makes sense that he's creeping out there
in the mcu somewhere
how does ghost rider get his powers
methisto who originally took wanda's
kids from her
mephisto and who do we think we see in
that loki trailer
mephisto i really do think he's coming
but for those of you who are rolling
your eyes at me right now i will put
that aside for a bit
regardless it does seem like there's a
monster verse
supernatural verse coming to the mcu and
with that comes very powerful
supernatural villains in the marvel
universe in general we have mephisto
c'thun who could have very well been set
up in one division
schumacher who is just reported to be
the villain of doctor strange 2 which
means it's all kind of starting to add
up
nightmare who was supposed to come in
doctor strange and then was supposed to
come in doctor strange too but it looks
like they're saving him for later
and many more awesome supernatural
villains that it looks like our
supernatural avengers the midnight suns
are going to have their hands full with
and i for one
am insanely excited to see what road
marvel studios is going to go with
for the midnight suns and the villains
that they're going to go with as well
so be sure to subscribe so you stay up
to date on everything relating to this
super
natural slash monster verse side of the
mcu and the midnight suns in the
meantime let me know how excited are you
for this new team
and who do you think the villains of the
supernatural verse are going to be
let me know down below don't forget to
like the video and for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof